i think um i was poised to love men
named steven
first of all steven spielberg and you
you both
set me up for the life i have it was
mine to screw up
i think i've come full circle everything
seems okay
um relatively speaking but you were such
an important person to me when i was a
kid because
we did fire starter together this little
picture says
to steven i love you dearly
drew barrymore and it's hung on my
office wall
for well over 40 years
yeah it was 1982 uh
that we did fire starter we actually
made
two movies that's right we made fire
starter
and cat's eye catch eye that's right
those years with you and meeting tabitha
and your whole family and being in your
family home and in your world
was um very important to me
and it made important lifelong
impressions that i hold so dearly in my
heart
that's good and not only were you uh
a great actress very very young
you were a good person and you're still
a good person and having written a book
wildflowers you should go get it now
oh goodness i'm sorry
the fact that you've heard of my book
the one and only the greatest
most important writer i i i
i'm just now thinking of uh jane fonda's
speech at the golden globes and i
thought not only was she the most
eloquent human to
ever speak but she talked about the
importance of storytelling
and how it isn't fantasy
it's a way to bring in our human
connectivity
stories are great and i love them and i
love to tell them
and i love when people say you know
your story meant something to me uh my
favorite story of all times
i was in uh a publix market uh down in
florida and i came around the corner
and there was a lady in one of those uh
little scooter carts that they have
and and she said i know who you are
you're stephen king
you write those horror stories well i
don't like horror stories very much
but i respect your right to tell him and
i said well i also wrote a
she said i i like stories like the
shawshank redemption
you're like i wrote that i i said i
wrote that and she said no you didn't
i've been thinking a lot about in the
stand you predicted a pandemic
and we're a year into this one
and i am wondering what your opinion is
on the fact that we have called it
social distancing was that a mistake
should we have called it physical
distancing have we created a monster of
fear
amongst us humans
well you know that's that's a really
good question and there are things
about i understand social distancing in
the sense that
you know if you're with a bunch of
people try to stay as far away
to so that the germs don't spread and
all that but boy
i miss being able to shake somebody's
hands i mean there's something cool
about
giving them an elbow and all that but
you know
we could do this in person if it wasn't
for this thing and drew i could give you
a hug
we can't do that anymore you know that's
not something that's happening hopefully
it will again
i'm interested to see how books novels
and movies will handle
the pandemic it's very tough to tell for
instance a love story like
what are these guys going to do and the
the boy and the girl when they finally
get together
do they sort of rip off their masks and
kiss or do they kiss through the masks
or exactly what do they do
it's going to be tough and they're going
to have to be some changes
the anxiety is is everywhere i think
we're going to need to find
through storytellers like you guides of
how we will refine
romance how we will refine connectivity
how we will be able to
overcome the fears and anxieties and
we're going to need
smart brilliant minds like yours to
guide
us out of this well you don't want to
stay inside too long think about jack
nicholson in the shining
you know people get a little bit freaky
when they spend too much time by
themselves
[Music]